in world war one both sides tried to
recruit other nations to join them and
tip the balance in their favor the
ottomans the italians and the romanians
being some of those enticed into joining
the conflict yet spain a country of 20
million people at the time managed to
stay neutral throughout the entire thing
and given that both sides were trying to
bribe up new allies why did spain sit it
out why did spain stay neutral in the
first world war before getting specific
it's important to know that as of 1914
spain wasn't having a good time its
economy was sluggish it had barely
industrialized it was deeply divided
internally and militarily things were
worse just before the war the spanish
had suffered military humiliation in
morocco when they tried to expand their
influence there in 1909 they did manage
to defeat the rebelling moroccans
eventually but that wasn't until after
numerous defeats in the sending of tens
of thousands of troops to morocco to
defeat one twentieth of their number and
so when franz ferdinand visited sarajevo
to try his hand at being assassinated it
wasn't long until world war one was well
on its way spain immediately declared
its neutrality and wanted nothing to do
with the war and the overriding reason
was simple it felt that it had nothing
to gain the previous spanish-american
war had taught spain that warfare was
painful even if the fighting stayed away
from the homeland and for many the
potential gains weren't even that great
if they joined the central powers then
spain could have potentially gained
gibraltar or something but that would
involve spain having to go toe-to-toe
with the well-equipped and well-trained
anton troops and given the previous
disaster in morocco spain wasn't ready
for that and if spain had joined the
anton then it may have been able to gain
some possessions in africa or
potentially in the pacific but the
benefits would have been little and
there was the potential for retaliation
furthermore spain had no quarrel with
germany or austria-hungary nor did it
have any feelings of kinship towards
serbia or belgium which gave them no
reason to join and even if the
government had wanted to pick a side and
ignored the risks there was the second
reason they didn't join political
instability spain's people were
extremely divided between the
assassination of the archduke and the
signing of the treaty of versailles
spain had nine governments headed by
four different prime ministers
each had preferences towards the ontart
or the central powers but all of them
preferred neutrality for the third
reason spain stayed out of the war cash
being neutral meant that you could sell
stuff to both sides and spain did very
well for itself doing just that it sold
food and raw materials to the untaunted
chemicals and textiles to the central
powers the influx of money saw spain's
industrialization speed up and spain's
gold reserves increased massively and
the fourth reason was that nobody else
wanted spain to join the central power
was wanted in neutral spain which could
be used for espionage and some trade and
the anton wanted spain to stay out of
the war since they didn't want to share
any of the potential spoils in africa
with them and thus neutrality was a
simple risk-free option but there were
some issues germany sank spanish
shipping which led to prime minister
alvaro de
are getting fired when he tried to
denounce germany for it and spain was
also threatened with invasion by the
anton when german troops fled into
spanish guinea and they didn't do much
about it of course spain managed to
maneuver through these issues and stay
neutral throughout the war and you would
assume that the massive influx of money
into spain would make the lives of
spaniards better but you would be wrong
workers saw no wage rises which led to
more and more of them turning to
anarchism or socialism to help and when
it became clear to farmers that it was
much more profitable to sell food to
italy or france than it was to the
spanish there were food shortages too
and so it won't surprise you that even
though spain avoided the horrors of
world war one it entered the post-war
world an even more divided nation but
that was a problem for another time i
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching with a special thanks
to my patrons james bissonette kelly
moneymaker corso wolfe adam stalter
jerry lamdin jordan longley rod d martin
lion hockey gustav swan spencer
lightfoot captain cydog winston k wood
boogery wiggly marvin castle aaron the
white words about books podcast commun
yoon matthew shipley maxon flutio alex
schwinn maggie patzkowski marcus asner
the mug whopper corey turner anthony
beckett coppertone spinning three plates
charles the first ben evanson and
scottish trekkie